so you're touring with Steve Martin yeah
and well you know at his age he doesn't
really tour he just wanders off I was
excited because I loved the show that
you two do together
yeah you did it's absolutely a joy
absolutely joy and now you have a deal
with Netflix bought the show yeah so
everyone's gonna get to see it it is
good to be on Netflix I'm not sure when
but it's a promotional cuz we have a
promotional clip that announces that
this show is going to be on Netflix with
Steve and Marty let's take a look yeah
yeah I'm often asked who do you think
was the greatest stand-up of the late
70s and I always answer it was you Steve
Thank You Marty you know we are both so
excited because we are going to be
taping our live show for necklace and
we're going to be working with the best
video people in the business yeah when
did you first get Netflix oh I think
when I was five I could just get the
local channels and the Netflix oh I love
history so we'll see you in a few months
Netflix people
marnya Steve's Netflix special and
evening you will pretend for the rest of
your life will be released later this
year you can see them live March 8th in
Chattanooga Tennessee March 9th in
Jacksonville Florida and for two shows
March 10th in Fort Lauderdale
Martina si will be touring all through
the u.s. check when they're coming to a
city near you if you don't go and see
this show you're an idiot
it is absolutely fantastic seriously I
absolutely love it I kind of set up good
about it mister Martin Short
always
[Applause]
you